it's no secret that as gamers
we struggle with things from time to
time whether it's not getting what we
want
mozambique
it's a mozambique
weapon skin
i got a mozambique weapon skin dude a
lack of support
wait why not are you baiting me raised
what are you doing
or never-ending grappling matches with
our own personal demons
[Music]
this game and for those who picked
streaming as their career path those
struggles are often magnified tenfold
the long hours where you constantly have
to be on the persistent fear of losing
viewership based on which game you're
playing and the pressure of the
spotlight all take their toll oh my god
[Applause]
better known as dr k comes in he's an
american psychiatrist who's made it his
life's mission to help everyone's
favorite twitch personalities confront
their mental health in a way that's
not so conventional
the ultimate way to come up for air is a
dick joke
that's yeah
to tie a dick joke into my dad's death
would be phenomenal
yeah i'll come up with one rigor mortis
who knows
so what inspired a video game addicted
monk to dedicate himself to helping
those whose lives unfold in front of a
webcam overcome their challenges how
does he find people willing to lay bare
their darkest deepest secrets in front
of thousands of viewers and how has dr k
himself been able to adapt to becoming
twitch's mental health champion so
here's the problem you need to stop
living your life based on my validation
you have to decide for yourself
right that's the fundamental problem
[Applause]
hey guys so before we dive into dr k
story in place of a sub throw i just
wanted to warn you that in this video we
will be touching explicitly on the topic
of suicide and suicidal ideation
and to tell you that if you
or anyone you care about is dealing with
thoughts of self-harm we've provided
links in the description that we hope
can be of help okay so whether you know
much about therapy or are based enough
to actively engage in it
most people generally view it as an
intensely private experience let's get
back to that kabuku
all this from a slice of a goal but
thanks to the ever extending reach of
the internet instead of having to unload
your insecurities in the all too
stereotypical setting that is a
therapist's couch you can now connect
with a trained professional from the
comfort of your own home which is
obviously great for those of us whose
lives are shielded from the prying eyes
of strangers but what about the people
who spend all their time connecting with
others online those who've made a career
out of sharing
and sometimes over sharing themselves
with others through live streaming
when's the last time you've had diarrhea
i'm not gonna tell you
i could tell you
tell me this morning after a huge
protein shake in mexican food last night
could a person person-to-person exchange
really do the trick for someone used to
getting feedback from hundreds or even
thousands of people all at once well
that's where dr k comes into the picture
but in order to understand how he became
a gaming's poster boy for mental health
awareness we need to go back to the good
doctor's youth i'm the son of uh you
know two indian immigrants
and uh
grew up you know kind of in east texas
where i was
smaller and scrawnier than most of my
classmates
and so kind of fell into gaming because
that was where i could compete
unfortunately what started as a way to
cope with being daintier than his peers
had devolved into a full-blown addiction
by the time our boy was entering his
college years
an addiction that almost resulted in him
flunking out entirely and then i'd get
into these cycles of just like gaming
all day and then like skipping class and
then it would get worse and then i was
behind and then like i didn't know how
to catch up and it just became this
vicious cycle where you know i was
basically failing out so i loved that in
india i discovered a way to understand
myself to understand where my desires
came from kind of why i did the things
that i did and decided to become a monk
yeah you heard that right dr k abandoned
his gaming rig and spent most of his 20s
training to one day become a monk
although by his own admission his
initial reason for choosing the monastic
life
wasn't exactly healthy you know you get
zero percent rejected from jobs
if you apply to zero jobs
zero rejection
safety
and so the way that i did that in my
mind was like i was gonna take all those
feelings if i'm a piece of [ __ ] and then
i said i'm better oh i'm gonna be a monk
i'm going to give up
it's not it's not in cell it's like
voluntary celibacy but after dedicating
so much time to ditching the material
plane
dr k's life took a
wild turn he fell in love with his
eventual wife kruti and after some
serious soul searching chose medical
school as his way forward he was
accepted into harvard's psychiatry
program and after completing his
education decided to redirect his
attention to the issue that kicked off
his own journey you know no one was
really talking to gamers no one was like
really seemed to care about gamers from
a mental health standpoint and these are
my people they're the same struggles
that i had growing up i saw a piece of
myself in other people and i know that
like when i was failing out of college
there really wasn't anyone to help me
and so that's what we're trying to
change with healthy gamer for those of
you who don't know
healthygamer.gg is an online mental
health resource for gamers seeking help
that dr k developed and officially
launched with his wife in 2019.
initially his content focused on smaller
candid therapy sessions with friends who
were struggling in their day-to-day
lives but eventually as his name became
more widely known dr k's services began
to attract streamers specifically later
that year dr k began broadcasting his
healthy gamer sessions live on twitch
and while his traffic was slow initially
those early discussions proved to be a
valuable learning experience for
everyone involved can i just say as well
actually
the last bit of this conversation has
been something that i wanted to avoid
bringing up because it makes me kind of
scared so the fact that you got it out
of me i
normally i probably would have just
tried to veer off and talk about
something else or cut the conversation
short but
i mean i figured it'd be better for
myself my mental state the stream as
well maybe to discuss it and
kind of learn to deal with it i guess
and i think a lot of um streamers and
content creators are in a unique
position to sort of share something
publicly using a platform that allows
them to connect with a lot of people i
do think it's a little bit of a
double-edged sword because showing who
you are on stream some people will
resonate with positively but it can also
open you up to toxicity if you guys
keep talking [ __ ]
about any of my friends
i will disable chat
and i don't care
having a chat room
isn't worth it if it's gonna be garbage
on top of his live one-on-ones dr k
continued to make content focused on the
issues that gaming personalities in
particular struggle with from healthy
living practices to building social
circles offline but it was after he
streamed several eye-opening sessions on
depression and suicidal thoughts with
beloved twitch streamer byron reckful
bernstein that people really began to
realize that what you saw on stream
wasn't always the full story
oh man when i was uh in high school or
20 or something
i didn't see i didn't imagine that when
i'm 30 i'll be a person who's alone this
often
i didn't think that would happen
it seemed like a lot of what reckful had
to say resonated with the internet
generation in a way that had not only
never been said before
but
quite literally broadcasted and the open
and honest exchange really shown a light
on the importance of the conversations
dr k was hosting but the thing about
therapy is that it isn't a quick fix and
there are no guarantees that come with
it
and in spite of the headway that reckful
appeared to be making in the summer of
2020
tragically
he took his own life to the shock and
dismay of the entire gaming community
including dr k every time i work with
someone i i give a piece of myself to
them
and yesterday the piece that i had given
to reckful died with him now in the wake
of such devastating news it's very easy
to imagine a scenario in which mental
health issues were shoved even further
under the rug
but
fortunately
that's not what happened instead more
streaming personalities came forward
inspired by reckful to share their
struggles effectively starting a
movement to destigmatize therapy and
debunk the idea that needing mental
health support
is something to be ashamed of and dr k
was more than happy to provide a
platform to help spread that message so
like my brother and i like to joke he's
my younger brother i'm like the beta
product and he's like the final product
my brother had no issues like he went to
like an engineering college he's great
he's fine he's
super healthy
and how are you
me
right like sadness is not an identity
cowardly is an identity you see that
yeah if you don't understand something
in a relationship
maybe try asking the other person
i have never tried that once ever
and therein lies i think a major piece
of social conditioning that you probably
never saw at home
in just a few short years dr k had
emerged from obscurity to become an
institution on twitch he wasn't just
helping streamers
he'd become one himself
and of course that meant that just like
his subjects he would occasionally get
memed on by his audience
okay dr k
gets into
a heated argument that pokes a hole in
this usually my experience with with
people who are super into logic is that
if their logic is incorrect they get
really really angry and then they just
can't see that their logic is wrong it
doesn't change the two are completely
unrelated like
like how the [ __ ] just look at that it's
even now the way that when you get mad
at yourself you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about sounds like you're
just a loser memes aside dr k's
involvement with gamers has extended
even beyond twitch as of late as someone
who's immersed in the streaming sphere
it was only a matter of time before he
crossed paths with esports and so after
a year of working with evil geniuses
dota 2 roster who let's be honest have
often choked at big tournaments dr k was
invited to accompany the team to ti 10
as their performance and mental health
coach and i've been in ten situations
like i've been in you know board rooms
where people are like arguing and like
ceos are about to get fired and like
super awkward stuff right like very
challenging things like
being yelled at in the emergency room
when someone who's like rich and
powerful is going to sue you because
you know their son relapsed again or
whatever like there have been a lot of
stressful situations i've been in but
like ti is just a whole different
experience it is hands down the most
stressful experience of my life for
working with dr k now like we have a lot
of emphasis on making sure everyone is
in their best state and fertile like his
what one of his best attributes is he's
good at making people get in the state
of like
energy basically right so yeah so yeah
that was there was a lot of yelling a
lot of swearing i'm pretty i'm pretty
sure it wasn't you know not not for true
sight so good thing it was first round
you know but yeah i mean it helps
everyone to get in a good mood and get
that energy going so yeah that's nice in
the end eg took a pretty early exit from
the competition once the main event was
underway but as disappointing as that
may seem the important thing is that
they took control of their circumstances
and tried something new which is
basically the entire point of therapy
performance-centric or otherwise and it
illustrates why what dr k is doing is so
crucial in life like it's okay to be
disappointed in what you do it's okay to
be like not happy with your performance
but be careful and remember that just
because you're not happy or it's okay to
be disappointed in like the most recent
thing doesn't mean that you don't
deserve to feel some amount of pride in
like what you've done prior to that day
to some his approach may seem strange
and indeed unprecedented but you have to
remember that we live in unprecedented
times just a few short years ago an
esports psychologist wasn't even a thing
that existed teams had to just deal with
their issues the best they could and
hope it all worked itself out even when
the root causes of those issues were
textbook psychology classics like a lack
of motivation or communication problems
between team members and as for
difficulties that gamers and streamers
face it is still a field so massively
underrepresented through traditional
mental health support avenues that you'd
be pretty hard-pressed to find
specialized help even if you sought it
out a lot of people kind of in the you
know the baby boomer generation and
stuff will they'll blame millennials and
jen's ears but i don't think they
understand that like it's just a
fundamentally different world that we
live in
so started streaming to try to support
these people because when these people
would go to
see mental health professionals like
they'd get diagnosed with depression
started on a medication and sent home
but that sort of doesn't work so what do
you do when you're dealing with
something that no generation ever before
has dealt with
well
and forgive the petty analogy
like any gamer struggling to overcome a
boss
you might look up a walk through and for
an entire swath of the population out
there dr k and his streams are a way to
do just that except with serious real
life [ __ ] that starts to become
approachable the second you open up
about it anita have you been
i've been all right yeah busy busy busy
but getting more sleep and taking a
little bit more care of myself than i
used to so that's great i'm really happy
to hear that seriously i i think you
deserve to take care of yourself you
deserve to be cared for by yourself at
the end of the day we are all
human and we can all use a little bit of
help sometimes regardless of the size of
the spotlight that shines upon us we all
face challenges in life and we all react
to them differently and while some of us
may still not be willing to talk about
our struggles to people we've never met
thanks to the efforts of dr k the
conversation surrounding mental health
on twitch is starting to become normal
and i think that that's something that
we can all get behind and what we've
really found at hg is that
community is a huge aspect of getting
your life together so there's sort of
this idea that you know self-help and
like you can like read a book and you're
kind of like working kind of on your own
to fix things
but in my experience of putting my own
life together community was a huge part
of it so that's why you know when i went
to india
and started like learning meditation and
eventually decided to become a monk a
huge part of that was that i was with a
group of people who were going through
similar things you know and that
community aspect
isn't just like a twitch thing for me
it's it's a life thing
you know just be good to everyone and
hopefully it all makes the world a
better place
yeah man
like it's been a shoe something i don't
know what you're saying
say it again say it slower
my first year's i thought i thought you
were saying my first sheila and i was
like
wrong continent matt like i don't like
you're not australian homie you're
cheeky sword
[Music]
cheeky sad